first up we've got the sweetest story
about actor and dad john stamos the blog
scary mommy reports that he just posted
this video of his son billy
watching his new favorite show
[Applause]
[Applause]
billy was never interested in full house
in fact he was on the show
and he talked about that
and
all of a sudden his son
is in the full house
and i don't know if it has john or
people wondering if it has anything to
do with maybe bob saget above alluring
like billy into his orbit um but
recently billy has been obsessed oh
that's very very sweet and like welcome
to the club billy i grew up on um on
full house did you watch it when you
were growing up i did watch it yeah of
course oh my god have mercy
yeah well i love the idea that he's
showing his son his old show and it made
me wonder if your girls had seen any of
your movies like i have a list here oh
okay so can i just ask have they seen
e.t
uh yes um
yes
um
they
they they're just they're not as into it
yet
which is weird but the 40th anniversary
is coming up oh yeah um wow so i know so
i think when they saw it they were just
too young um
and but i think this time when we see it
it's gonna be very meaningful what about
fire starter are you going to show them
that one they haven't seen fire starter
and i want them to at some point because
i am worried there because already olive
like was burning a piece of paper the
other day and i was like i mean you know
when you want to have a serious talk
with your child yeah and you're like i
don't even want to go the angry route
because i'm so scared and freaked out
that you're going to burn the house down
i'm going to go like the
anomaly this is going to freak you out
because i'm not coming in like listen
yeah like i'm like oh
olive
this is so serious
that's what you did yes well don't show
them fire starter because they'll be
like uh mom did you see what you did
hello also i feel like olive doesn't
need any she already likes matches and
oh wow handles and i'm like oh god i
cannot show them fire starter no keep
her away from me i am way too flaming
for that i'll just go up like that
keep her away from uncle ron she loves
you
she loves you
they frankie says she will not see
scream until she's 28 28. she doesn't
want to see mom get slashed but she's
really into like she knows it's all
filmmaking and
she's very aware of that and she's
really into technicality they're like 50
first dates um charlie's angels because
they've seen that one yeah and they call
them mom movies but i don't like which
is so cute it's the sweetest thing i've
ever heard in my life it's cute but i
don't force them on them like they come
to them on their own and naturally oh my
god i would so force it on my kids i'd
be you're going to watch it and you're
going to praise me look at daddy look
look what i did
that's what i would do well oh i love
that interesting conversation oh that's
fun thank you cute
[Music]